kenneth timerman ex conseiller aux
affaires étrangères de donald trump lors
de la campagne présidentielle de 2016
kenneth timmerman bonjour merci d'être
avec nous cet après midi en direct sur
rt france on vient de voir deux sujets
sur le traité ciel ouvert définitivement
clos sur le traité new start qui a été
prolongé en janvier dernier on se
souvient également du traité est fait ni
sur les forces
de portée intermédiaire en termes de
stabilité stratégique à quoi faut-il
s'attendre cet après midi à genève
très franchement je m'attends pas à
grand chose
joe boyd est un président assez faible
et on voit par exemple que il n'a pas de
tête à tête avec la lumière poutine il
va avec ses conseillers
quand les briquets ce n'est pas un
président à part entière nous disons aux
états unis c'est le président de
l'établissement américain et donc il a
besoin d'autres autour de lui et il y a
eu un tournure dans l'établissement
américain aussi bien sous la présidence
de dans l'autre que maintenant contre la
russie est contre ces accords de pas
seulement sur le nucléaire mais n'a
openskies notamment un accord sur le
contrôle damon et n'est aussi bon que la
vérification et quand on a les problèmes
de vérification l'accord ne vaut plus
rien c'est le problème qu'on a vu avec
l'accord nucléaire avec lyon c'est le
problème avec openskies et c'est très
probablement le problème également avec
le nul store alors autre point je
voudrais souligner le new start a été
signé par barack obama qui avait dit
médias à l'époque dit à vlad
c'est d'ailleurs la limite poutine dit
vlad qu'après mon réélection en 2012 je
peux être plus souple plus flexible à
négocier d'autres accords
donc on a eu un gouvernement américain
sur baidu et obama qui voulait négocier
des traités avec la russie qui voulait
donner des concessions à poutine
et maintenant on voit que brydon à la
tête de la maison blanche fait
volte-face et veulent faire plus dur on
va plus catholique que le pape vous êtes
l'ancien conseiller de donald trump pour
la politique étrangère
en quoi justement la politique étrangère
de joe biden
change avec la ligne de donald trump
mais c'est intéressant de voir une
certaine continuité
surtout vis-à-vis tashi chose que moi je
m'y attendais pas j'attendais à ce que
baidu vu l'argent que son fils fraser
avait pris du gouvernement chinois un
milliard et demi de dollars de
placements en bourse aux états unis je
m'attendais à ce que ben ali soit plus
ouvert la chine plus souples vis-à-vis
la chine mais non pas du tout il est
aussi dur que dans l'antre empilant même
pas enlever des tarifs imposées par
trompe à juste titre à cause du trucage
enfin les chinois qui trichent et tout
le temps vis-à-vis de la russie
il faut comprendre aux états unis le
parti démocrate et puis quatre ans est
parti on le djihad contre la russie
tandis que dans l'autre amp
il voulait faire en fait joué l'amitié
entre les des hommes des dirigeants
trempe a toujours cru comme il a fait
avec le nokia
korian il a toujours cru que par sa
personnalité
la force de sa joie de vivre qui pouvait
convaincre des dirigeants même hostile
aux états unis a au moins trop père et
leur assaut hostilités il
il a réussi avec la corée du nord il n'a
pas tout à fait réussi avec la russie
parce qu'il a toujours eu des démocrates
terrien nuit qui poussait ce jihad
contre la russie j'ai longtemps
j'entends encore ces jours-ci d'aidé des
représentants du parti démocrate au
congrès et dans les médias
dire que bayrou va confronter poutine
sur l'ingérence russe tour des élections
américain de 2016 et que trempe avait
choqué tous ses conseillers en 2018
quand il a rencontré le footing à
helsinki en disant qu'ils ne croyaient
pas ses propres services de
renseignements sur cette ingérence
or on sait maintenant quatre ans plus
tard qu'il n'y a pas une ingérence russe
dans l'élection de 2016 et que trempe
avait raison et que les les soi-disant
services de renseignement américains ont
toutes été dirigée par les
aux schistes des gens qui restait de
l'époque
obama et on laissait un pétard dans la
cuisine second volet avec ce fameux
rapport du janvier 2017 sur le
soi-disant ingérence rustan les
élections qui n'existait pas je n'estime
herman on vient de voir un sujet des
mini google sur la rencontre il ya trois
ans entre donald trump et vladimir
poutine en juillet 2018 et quels
souvenirs avez-vous de cette de cette
rencontre est de cette conférence de
presse commune qu'il n'y aura pas ce
soir puisque ce soit en rappel ce sont
deux conférences de presse séparées
d'abord vladimir poutine puis joe biden
sur la demande de la maison blanche
mais exactement et c'est important de
l'indiquer diot by dell ne veut pas
prendre le risque était quelqu'un qui
prend des risques et l'a dit voilà je
vais faire une conférence de presse
commune avec avec poutine
parce que qui sait ce qui va se passer
bein ne peut pas improviser
ils ne font pas des questions des
journalistes lorsqu'il à des questions
de journalistes il ne sait pas comment
répondre
il répond à des questions qui n'ont pas
été posées il ne répond pas aux
questions posées
donc c'est quelqu'un qui n'est pas très
présent dans un débat dans une
conférence de presse yves tout soit
script et même la conférence qu'il
arrive à l'otan lundi je pense il lisait
les noms des journalistes et il lisait
des questions des journalistes et
ensuite ils lisent et sur le
téléprompteur ses propres repose donc
tout a été préparé à l'avancé vois je
vois en 2018 que trempe voulait dire ce
qu'ils pensaient être la vérité il avait
vu qu'il n'ait pas eu d'ingérence russe
en 2016 il savait pertinemment seule
chose qu'on a trouvé c'était 200 mille
dollars de publicité sur facebook
achetés par des entités russes après les
élections pas durant des élections donc
c'était complètement farfelu et tout ce
dossier tout ce dossier d' ingérence
russe s'était tenue d'un en fait d'un
type christopher ce tir de l'ancien des
services britanniques qui peut-être
agents russes c'est tout à fait possible
mais c'est lui qui a inventé de toutes
pièces des babas de bobards de trompes à
moscou et c'est pour avoir votre âge
votre réaction est joué je vous
comprends pas votre réaction selon un
haut responsable américain à l'instant
je cite moscou protège les pirates
informatiques basés sur son seul comment
est-ce que vous réagissez à ce qui vient
de tomber
alors ça c'est autre chose ça c'est
autre chose je pense que là il ya des
informations assez étoffé sur des cas là
ya pas de travail pour l'instant dont il
n'y a pas de preuves mais il ya des
indications qui viennent pour le voit
des membres du congrès qui cite et
services de renseignement n'est ce pas
c'est comme ça qu'on sait des choses aux
états unis il semblerait qu'il ya des
indications c'est assez poussée de la
place l'implication de beauce québec au
bout dit il n'y a pas de preuve encore
et encore de preuves mais je peux vous
dire de mes propres sources aux états
unis que les russes sont très très
actifs ils sont très surveillées
également par les renseignements
américains dans le domaine du cyber le
planning l'agenda a été respecté à la
lettre en ce qui concerne des horaires
est ce que vous êtes surpris comment ce
qui vous analyser cela non je suis pas
surpris et écouter le tout c'est que
baye djiby éviter la tête la tête à tête
avec poutine il voulait éviter la
conférence de presse commune et avoir le
plus dépensier possible avec lui dans la
salle parce que en fait il est président
d' équipe s'ils voudraient et au libre
et ken sont secrétaires d'état ces
séries qui tient le plus la politique
trop cher on l'a vu notamment avec ses
déclarations vis-à-vis de la chine
et je pense qu'on va avoir cet après
midi avec la déclaration plus tard après
que après cette conférence de presse la
liberté
donc on le rappelle un les pourparlers
au phoma au format élargi sont terminées
en
la délégation américaine et la
délégation russe
cana timerman on a vu les images de joe
biden quitter la ville à la grange on a
vu rentrer dans sa limousine ou est-ce
qu'il est parti selon vous il regagne
son hôtel intercontinental de genève
s'est depuis là-bas qu'il tiendra sa
conférence de presse ou bien ce qu'il va
selon vous revenir au parc la grange
pour redonner une conférence de presse à
son tour
alors là honnêtement je n'ai aucune idée
je faisais les journalistes sur place
qui ne saurait mais n'ont aucune idée
probablement à l'automne mais je n'ai
pas d'information là-dessus et une
déclaration de john des mères sans
charge des questions sécurité nationale
au ministère de la justice américain
je cite il ya beaucoup d' attaque aux
rançons jl menait depuis le territoire
russe le gouvernement russe ne se
contente pas de les tolérer il se met en
travers des efforts des autorités
américaines pour les combattre à cette
question qui était donc au menu un de ce
rendez vous au sommet avec également la
pandémie de kobe de 19
la coopération économique le climat
l'arctique les conseils régionaux ou
encore la stabilité stratégique kahn
estime erman en tant qu'ex conseiller
aux affaires étrangères de donald trump
lors de la campagne présidentielle de
2016 comment est-ce que vous réagissez
aux déclarations de john des moeurs est
selon vous donc là ce sont encore des
allégations n'y a pas de preuve et
comment vladimir poutine va répondre à
cela lors de sa conférence de presse on
voit des images en direct
que va dire le président russe à ce
propos selon vous où la lumière foutel
il va balayer toutes ces accusations
mais je trouve très intéressant que vous
avez un haut responsable du département
de justice dans des pompes fp à faire
une déclaration qui accuse l'état russe
de ne pas intervenir pour bloquer des
cyber criminels et qui qui les accusent
aussi des russes -dont empêcher les
américains d'agir contre il faut
comprendre que j'aimerais qu'un ils ont
beaucoup
moyen de apercevoir les activités des
supers criminels et ils veulent pas
toujours dire d'où ça vient
on essaye par exemple peut dire ils ont
fait avec la chine il ya quelques années
ils peuvent identifier jusqu'à environ
100 m les meubles dans laquelle donner
l'origine d'une attaque de cyber
criminels est en concurrence avec la
chine sont des immeubles qui est
contrôlé par l'armée populaire chinois
notamment une unité connus pour leur
superbe pour l'informatique
donc je trouve intéressant ça vient du
département de justice est plus étoffé
que n'importe quel dirigeant politique
une information qui vient de tomber kahn
estime norman la conférence de presse de
joe biden aura lieu à 19h30 ce sera donc
après a priori celle de vladimir poutine
qui va s'exprimer d'ici quelques minutes
on l'aperçoit les journalistes sont
présents dans la salle de presse de la
ville à la grange à genève le fait que
joe biden s'exprime après vladimir
poutine
comment est-ce que vous réagissez à cela
sachant qu'en 2018 c'est l inverse une
conférence de presse commune mais la
diva poutine avait pris la parole avant
donald trump d'ailleurs ça avait été
interprété ça a été très critiqué outre
atlantique vous savez en politique c'est
toujours mieux d'avoir le dernier mot
je pense que c'est ça que baye leurs
avoirs il va pouvoir contrer ce qu'il
dit pour ni poutine s'il dit des choses
que il pense qu il est vrai compterait
donc c'est à cet âge heures politique
il a gagné sur ce petit point si vous
voulez c'est un jeu d'enfant
à mon avis ça devrait commencer de
manière imminente à l'image a frisé on
l'a vu juste à côté de vous les hauts
dirigeants qui se prépare d'ailleurs on
le voit à l'image
il y a notamment sur la gauche sergei
lavrov le ministre des affaires
étrangères russe avec toute la
délégation russe qui est donc là pour
assister à cette conférence de presse
j'en profite pour rappeler que notre
envoyé spécial antoine claireaux au plus
proche de l'action est également à
créditer va pouvoir suivre tout ça il
nous fera évidemment un débrief de cette
conférence de presse lorsqu'elle sera
terminée
d'après vous
que va dire vladimir poutine et younes
meerman il va juste en profiter pour
dire quels points ont été abordés ou
est-ce qu'il va aller plus loin plus en
profondeur auprès des journalistes
à mon avis tout essayé de balayer les
accusations américaines sur le serveur
et criminalité sur l'intervention dans
les élections et probablement il va
essayer d'être un peu ouvert au dialogue
il va être se montrer un peu souple pas
de grande ourse deschamps et il en est
qui n'ont pas de plate forme maintenant
pour le faire les journalistes
américains ils viennent avec des tas de
questions très hostile mais le format de
traduction et sera en fête donne un
avantage certain à poutine pour balayer
tout cet ancien dj de la presse je pense
surtout il veut se montrer pas hostiles
mais un homme raisonnable